deswegen würde ich gerne mal fragen habt
ihr bock darauf dass ich ein projekt mit
logo mache
servus es geht und willkommen zu einer
neuen folge survival gamespot bier
tricks sowie games zeigt rum da haben
wir ein schwert of the match wird
erschwert oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] missgeburten arsch so leute ronaldo
r im duell mit spielern er auf die alte
medaille ist mein liebling ist hier
liest oben geile kiste road truckers
kunden goldabbau und top doch da sage
ich nicht nein da sag ich ja oder fonic
sehr gern makatsch hallo xxs kay
betreibt ein turnaround skill alter
kommt acht ihr seitdem erinnert am team
oder so weil ich glaube dass auch an -
wo kommt er her dass celtics alles klar
sixx ist da wieder das ist komisch aus
dass ich nicht angegriffen haben weiß
ich nicht wie das wirklich wahr stoff
verlangt alles klar
heute möchte ich gern zwei themen
ansprechen und intelligent wie ich bin
habe ich mir natürlich beide games als
spurlos rausgesucht den themen
ansprechen möchte wunderbar und zwar an
erster stelle soll es kurz darum gehen
was der nächste diese telekom wird
stichwort neues projekt
dazu möchte ich noch sagen und zweitens
um die loks und das benötigte equipment
was ich dafür verwenden anschaffen
möchte
ok als allererstes ich habe unter dem
letzten legend video und supertoll
kommentar gelesen der mich so doch
tatsächlich inspiriert hat man noch mal
in eine gewisse richtung was zu machen
und zwar hat er geweint
macht doch mal ein projekt mit logo ist
weil dadurch von grippe oder so kann ich
immer einblenden
der war relativ kugler viele likes
bekommen scheint also vielen fleischer
zu gehen deswegen würde ich gerne mal
fragen habt ihr bock darauf dass ich ein
projekt mit logo mache beispielsweise so
eine adventure map oder vielleicht auch
sogar chillige singleplayer sache man
sehr ist dinge irgendwie baut oder so
dass noch alles ganz diffus also
schreibt einfach meine kommentare wir
dazu stehen würde prinzipiell während
ich hier gar die sache nicht reporter
werfer jeder banken leiter guck dir das
angeguckt dir das an
da interessiert mich auch meine sehr
also ab in die kommentare damit und
jetzt zweiter stelle wieder in letzter
zeit kann man auf jeden fall zu wenige
blocks auf dem channel liegt einfach
daran dass ich keine videokamera ab und
jetzt wieder bei mir bin und ich und
mexiko pro aufnehmen kann
das wird sich bald ändern denn ich werde
mir auf jeden fall eine wie login kamera
zulegen
und jetzt wo ich ein bisschen eure hilfe
weil ich nicht weiß welche das werden
sollen ich habe natürlich kennen die
läger mixed durch standard sie haben
extrem viele und damit mich mal
interessieren die finde ich auch gerade
ganz spannende gibt es irgendwie ein
bisschen reduziert im internet kann man
es gut
toppen deswegen schreibt man die
kommentare wer von euch vielleicht eine
legale mix hat und wir wissen aus helfen
kann wissen erfahrt komplett david 35
ohne pizza wenn ich so schnell war wie
viel kann der denn bitte einstecken
müssen vielmehr jetzt der kassierer dem
gegenseitigen gegen rechts werden
notarzt ok danke
ja es war auch kein trauma ganz ganz
knappe sind das nicht weiß ein thema
sein soll
ok kurz reagan ja und ich wieder bin
kamera würde ich mir sehr gerne zulegen
weisheit aber nicht welche da könnte ich
eure hilfe sehr gut gebrauchen
liebe leute streit darum eine kommentare
was ihr von der termin ist am besten nur
wenn er die selbst auch habt irgendwie
also nur leute die auch wirklich dann
davon berichten können und zweitens zu
diesem für dieser widrigen sache aber
ich meine dass sie wieder ob es euch
gefallen dass das weiß ich ja also die
kommen natürlich super an mich mir macht
es spaß
ich würde auch gern ein bisschen mehr
abwechslung bringen nicht immer nur
gaming weil es einfach auch eine art von
unterhaltung ist die mir auch so viel
spaß macht und ich denke nicht spaß beim
aufnehmen dann schlägt sich das auch in
der qualität des videos wieder oder
nicht
deswegen eure meinung ist auch sehr
gerne in die kommentare
und natürlich auch zu alternativen
videokameras also was es sonst noch gibt
so klassische camcorder finde ich auch
mega cool von der form her ja okay du
bist als der verdauung ihr alles klar so
down sowie die klassischen crm sony ist
die erste marke die mir dazu ein für
diese klassischen teile die man halt so
hält hier und die den rechts und links
und bildschirmen zum aufklappen die
finde ich auch wieder cool werden da
guter fahrer hat zu einer kamera die
guten ton hat gutes bild dann schreibt
uns mal die kommentare und die meinung
zur liga und eure stellung zum projekt
mit logo und wie das projekt aussehen
könnte gerne die kommentar oder können
da es sich gefallen hat so wie immer
wir sind im nächsten video wieder raus
rein macht's gut